the family of a couple that was missing
in rural nevada say the pair went more
than a week without any food or water
the nephew of ronnie and beverly barker
sharing new details about the ordeal
after hearing from his aunt tonight she
told him the gps told them to take their
rv up a mountain road where it
eventually got stuck last sunday the
next day she says they unhooked the car
they were towing and drove down the
mountain to get help took a wrong turn
and became stuck again
well that's where they would spend the
next week collecting snow for water and
taking turns honking the horn in an sos
pattern ronnie passed away monday
afternoon less than two days later
though the couple was found and beverly
is back with her daughters
we're blessed
so many people
lose
relatives
and they just go missing
they they
they have the nightmare that we had for
nine days family of the barker say they
feel the search efforts dragged in a
statement they say changes need to be
made at all levels of public safety in
light of what happened to ronnie and
beverly